how's it going everybody it's Warren and
on Thursday Marvel hit us with a huge
surprise dropping the second official
trailer for Avengers endgame out of
nowhere and with the trailer came some
pretty big reveals and surprises
including Black Widow having her red
hair again
Captain Marvel showing up showing us
tiny little bits of battle scenes and of
course having Tony Stark and nebula back
on earth now we all knew that these were
coming and that they're going to be in
the movie but the real shocker was that
we actually saw them in the trailer we
knew Tony and nebula would eventually
get back to earth but we'd never
expected to see that in one of the
trailers so it was a surprise but it
wasn't the biggest surprise the biggest
surprise of the trailer was seeing the
Avengers in their white suits these
white suits were something that have not
been confirmed to be in the movie yet
until we got this trailer yes we had
seen concept art leaks and toy leaks but
sometimes those end up not being true or
are simply used just to sell toys of
course seeing the Avengers wear them in
an official Avengers and game trailer
confirms them to be true however after
they were confirmed by showing up in a
trailer the new question was now are
they actually quantum realm suits or are
they for travelling to space it is
widely believed that in the first half
of the movie the Avengers will actually
travel to Titan 2 to fight Thanos so now
people are thinking that these suits are
not for travelling inside of the quantum
realm but they're actually for
travelling to space but no need to
wonder anymore as Marvel themselves have
come out and stated what these suits are
for not too long after the trailer was
released Marvel came out with an article
on their official website talking about
the most surprising things we saw from
the trailer and coming in at number 6
was the new suits and this is what
Marvel had to say about them with the
team reassembled to take on Thanos we
see them sporting a unified team look
the new suits with the Avengers a
emblems seem inspired by a Hank Pym suit
he wore to rescue Janet Van Dyne in the
quantum realm at the end of ant-man and
the wasp this is something that we have
all been saying for a very long time
that these suits look just like the one
that Hank Pym wore in the quantum realm
to go save Janet but now no more need
for speculation as Marvel has confirmed
that these are quantum realm suits
modeled after the one that hank pym
designed again we know that the quantum
realm is going to play a huge role in
Avengers in game so it makes sense that
these suits are for travelling inside of
the quantum realm since we learned from
the very first ant-man movie that you do
need a special suit to travel inside of
the quantum realm and it seems like
ant-man comes back presents Tony Stark
with the new technology and then Tony
makes the suits because they have the
Avengers a emblem on them so there you
have it these suits are for travelling
inside of the quantum realm modeled
after the one that Hank Pym wore in a
man and the wasp and this is coming
directly from Marvel calm let me know
your thoughts about this and the
comments down below and a reminder about
my giveaway I'm giving away five imax
tickets right now if you'd like to
interfere your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and of
course be sure to subscribe if you want
to stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers endgame and Marvel
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]